Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Musica)
Ah-hey!
Buonasera, signore e signori,
e benvenuti nel mondo
della Gaudats Junk Band.
Questa è una band
che può suonare qualunque genere.
Rhythm and blues ragazzi, andiamo!
I can't turn you loose
I'm in love and you know it's true
I can't turn you loose now honey
But you know just what to do
I can't turn you loose to nobody
Nobody but yourself
I can't turn you loose now honey
But you know just what to help
Come on, you're gonna get your side:
I got to, got to, got to, got to,
got to, got to, got to, yeah!
Yeah!
E ora si rallenta, gente!
Rallentiamo.
Forse avremo bisogno
delle vostre mani: pronti?
Left a good job in the city
Working for a man, every night and day
I never lost a minute of sleeping
Till I took a ride on a riverboat queen
Big wheels keep on turning
I said, Proud Mary keep on burning
Rolling
Rolling on the river
I said rolling
Rolling
Rolling on the river
Uno, due, tre, quattro!
I left a good job in the city
Working for the man every night and day
I never lost one minute of sleep
Till I took a ride on a riverboat queen
Big wheels keep on turning
Proud Mary keep on burning
As we're rolling,
Rolling,
Rolling on the river
I said rolling,
Rolling,
Rolling on the river
Bene, forza!
E ora...
Vi voglio portare nel cuore
del sound Jamaicano,
fino al cuore del reggae, dai!
Forza forza forza!
Con le mani, dai!
Aiutatemi!
Sentiamo!
Could you be loved
and be loved?
Yeah!
Could you be loved
and be loved?
Don't let them fool ya
Or even try to school ya, all right now
We've got a life to live
They say, only, only
Only the fittest
of the fittest shall survive
Stay alive!
Could you be loved
And be loved?
Say something - Reggae, reggae -
Say something - Rockin', rockin' -
Say something - Only, only
Say something - All right!
Say something
Yeah!
E ora...
Funky!
You don't have to be beautiful
to turn me on
I just want your body, baby,
from dusk till dawn
It could be... experience to turn me on
You can leave it all up to me
We can have a good time, yeah
You don't have to be rich to be my girl
You don't have to be cool to rule my world
No particular sign I'm compatible with
I just want your extra time and your
Kiss!
Bravi!
You got to not talk dirty, baby,
if you wanna impress me
Act your age not your shoe size,
I know how to undress me
I wanna be your fantasy
Maybe you could be mine
Well just leave it all up to me
You can have a good time
All right, all right!
Don't have to be rich to be my girl
Don't have to be cool to rule my world
No particular sign I'm compatible with
Just want your extra time and your
Kiss!
E ora,
Ora sentiamo come suonano
questi strumenti da soli!
Western.
(Applausi)
E ora,
Sapete cosa vogliamo?
Un po' di sano rock and roll.
Torniamo agli anni 50!
Bene!
Dai, ormai lo sapete cosa dovete fare:
battere le mani con noi!
A little more conversation,
a little more action, please
All this aggravation ain't satisfying me
A little more bite, and a little less bark
A little more fight
and a little less spark
Open up and satisfy me.
Satisfy me!
Satisfy
Walking down the road alone
in a summer breeze
It's a groovy night
and I know just how to use it
All this aggravation, conversation
All this aggravation ain't satisfying me
A little more bite, and a little less bark
A little more fight
and a little less spark
Open up and satisfy me
Satisfy me!
Come on baby, I'm tired of talking
Grab your coat and let's start walking
Come on, come on
Get over here, tired of it,
take it round, yeah!
A little more conversation,
a little more action
All this aggravation ain't satisfying me
A little more bite, and a little less bark
A little more fight,
and a little less spark
Come on and satisfy me
Satisfy me!
Satisfy
(Applausi)
E ora,
che ne dite di un po' di metal?
Rock duro!
Questa la sapete, dai!
Living easy, living free
Season ticket on a one-way ride
Asking nothing, leave me be
Taking everything in my stride
Don't need reason, don't need rhyme
Nobody's gonna weigh me down
Looking down, party time
On my way with a friend or two
I'm on the highway to hell
Highway to hell
(Applausi)
- Grazie!! - E ora...
per finire,
per chiudere,
un po' di good old soul!
- Siete pronti ragazzi?
Uno, due, tre, yeah!
Siete pronti?
Cantate insieme a noil, dai!
Uno, due, tre, sììì!!!
Andiamo, su le mani!
Bene!
Vi vogliamo sentire!
Do the Maronie
The Bony Maronie
Hand on your hip
Yeah, you do it like this
Do the alligator
Yeah, the mashed potato
Do the Miss Lucy
Yeah, the little Miss Lucy
Come on!
Siete pronti?
Uno, due,
Uno, due, uno, due, tre, quattro!
Tutti! Forza!
Sììììì!
Bravissimi!
The Junk Band.
Questa è la Junk Band, signore e signori!
Tutti gli strumenti sono fatti
con materiali riciclati!
Noi siamo vestiti riciclati!
Noi, riciclati!
- Grazie infinite!! - Grazie a tutti!
Un ciao dalla Gaudats Junk Band!
Siete pronti?
E voi lo siete?
Uno, due,
Uno, due, uno, due, tre!
Ciao!
(Applausi)